hey reject nation Greg Alba here I'm
John we are dropping our reaction to
this trailer right on time only dropped
six hours ago and here we are today
uploading it an hour after we're done
shooting this is the none one of the few
successful cinematic universes outside
of the MCU check out this trip there's
been a lot of hype surrounding it want
to give a shout to our patreon where we
do full-length TV show reactions to many
a shows and a bunch of other goodies
over there a patron of the day shout out
for Scuba Steve Scuba Steve is a guy who
lives all the way on the east coast of
the world and he is an awesome graffiti
artist does plenty of illegal things
like that and ladies he is single right
now so you could find him on plenty of
fish and I'm telling you he's casting
his hook in the water right now he's
also a dude who loves a good horror
movie so I'm sure he'll be checking this
out most of the time I talked to him we
talked about horror films Scuba Steve
thank you so much for being a part of
our patreon keep tagging police cars and
ladies go look for him on Grindr and
after each one ended
this seemed far it'd be stuck in my head
[Music]
I saw none
where did my visions reach the church
and I was asked to accompany a priest to
an abbey in Romania the Abbey as a
[Music]
[Music]
theatre four days after my birthday hmm
Oh No
[Music]
my nipples are so
like I'll reverse the other end actually
one thing about having a horror be so
huge nowadays especially is you're
getting to watch as everybody tries to
figure out how to keep the jump-scare
fresh every single time why they say
watch the lienen is where people like
clicking off a trailer just one that
watch time they're really concerned
about their YouTube earnings over at
Warner Brothers Studios a lot of times
I'll think there are certain jump scares
that are clever and then other people
will hate the hell out of them I thought
that jump scare was really well done
because when the camera first pants back
whatever version of the none is behind
that others the faceless yeah yeah there
but they don't it's just casually
walking so when she turns around you
think the jump scares gonna come from
the nun behind you another one comes
from the side I thought that was very
clever because I just did not see that
the conjuring you traverse I like the
conjuring movies and I really like
Annabelle creation actually omit I did
not watch the first sign of all from
what I hear it's the best of all this
trailer the text for things seems to
really be hyping it along yeah
horrifying in darkest chapter and the
watch till the end before a conjuring
before Annabelle the scariest darkest
chapter of anything ever existing has
occurred you don't really need to do a
hell of a lot to really sell people on
this I feel like this is a spinoff
people actually have been looking
forward to since it was announced yeah I
mean that was a pretty freaky sequence
in the middle of the Kandra even though
it is the conjuring 2 even though it's
like kind of shoved in there it feels
like sort of like it definitely left an
impression on people so I can see why
they're excited we grew up Catholic but
when a church and all that so whenever I
see films that deal with religious
horror even though I don't consider
myself Catholic anymore it still messes
with my brain more than anything else
it's more than slasher more than a ghost
there's something about like religious
horror that
and to do spooky none yeah freaks me out
well I know we grew up with nuns and
stuff like that I'm not overly offended
by religious things anymore like you
know sacrilegious things coming up with
that as some of the formative ideas of
your life you can't help but feel
uncomfortable watching yeah yeah
religious horror always does get to me I
think back to the Condrey 2 trailer
where all the crosses on her walls start
flipping upside down there's something
so dark in a way that not all horror is
and so that gives me faith for this I'm
worried about any conjuring spin-off to
be honest because it seems like that's a
trickier pitch than something directed
by James Watt I'm sure of the production
values on this look really cool I like
that they're continuing with the period
aspect and now I just I guess I'm
wondering if it's Isaac Farmiga can like
carry this movie you know cuz like I
like her on American Horror Story and
stuff but she's not like the most
intense actor on that show by any
stretch so I'm hoping that this is a
good thing for her that was really good
scare it's not a full-on trailer so you
know not a hundred percent sure how the
whole movie will be but that was a
really really good spooky scared anytime
I see that none it does freak me out so
it was a pretty horrifying creature even
if it's cheap jump scares I'm sure it'll
still get me I mean if it's Winchester
well what'd you guys think of the nun
trailer how awesome was that that jumps
here legit got me that actually like a
really good you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification about the subscribe buttons
are broken look at most channels Butte
County and you can check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A zyk video coverage would love
to have you that's you you you you
become a patronage ektu day